thank you
welcome to session 70 of the worlds of
speculative fiction series I'm going to
tell you a little bit about the series
in just a minute but I want to highlight
the author and narrative universe and
specifically the books that we're going
to be talking about during this 70th
session so it is CJ Chara and what I've
got here in my hands are four volumes
actually this is one that's got two
different books in it from her Alliance
Union Universe a science fiction series
that is taking place after the
colonization of the Stars by human
beings moving out into the Galaxy but
not all that far quite yet as we're
going to talk about when we get to the
World building section of this and what
I've got here I was originally just
going to do these three three particular
novels and they have to do with the
perspectives and points of view of one
of the groups of people that are
incredibly important in this universe
the merchanters those who are going out
and traveling between the Stars
oftentimes stopping just at space
stations not actually doing Planet fall
or anything like that and carrying cargo
from place to place and occasionally
fighting and getting involved in the
conflicts between the other main
factions so we have one that's actually
named after a ship finity's end this is
quite a massive Tome it's well over 500
pages and then two other ones tri-point
which is actually referencing one of the
places where you would jump to with your
faster than light jump drives something
else we're going to be talking about in
this and then Rim Runners which actually
names a certain kind of
ship and crew and activity but I thought
it could also be good
to bring in merchanter's lock which is
another really cool fairly early uh
contribution to the story also about
merchanters and so there's a lot of uh
great stuff in all four of these I'll
mention that this this one labeled
Alliance space has merchander's luck and
forty thousand in gehenna put together
in kind of a interesting way so what is
Worlds of speculative fiction if you if
this is the first time you're
encountering it
let me tell you about the history so
this is a series that we started back in
2016 hosted originally as a face-to-face
get together once a month where I would
come in and talk about an author a set
of texts The Narrative worlds
philosophical themes and it was hosted
at the Brookfield Public Library when
covid hit we had to go go online so it's
now in this format that you see where I
will shoot a video like you're watching
right now talking for about 90 minutes
about different aspects of the author's
work sometimes bringing in things the
author him or herself has to say about
their own work from interviews or essays
and sometimes talking about reviews as
well and then we delve heavily into the
World building what kind of narrative
Universe do we have going on here and
some of these selected philosophical
themes philosophical in the broad sense
of dealing with the human condition as
well as topics and ethics or in
metaphysics even Aesthetics or
philosophy of Technology very important
for sci-fi series so what we're going to
be doing in this we've already done a
biography of CJ Chara in a pre previous
session so I don't need to go back over
that and I'll link to that previous set
session Below in the let's call them
show notes right the video description
you can click that see more and it
should come up for you so if you want
the biography of chero then that's
available for you I think we should jump
right into talking about this narrative
universe and then we'll get into you
know maybe some of the things that chera
herself has to say but looking
specifically at the worlds which are
really
ships ships and stations where these
people live although I have to correct
that to a certain extent finity's end is
going to begin on uh the world that is
um you know got some aliens there a
major food producing place the down
below of down below station at Pell so
we'll we'll go into that so the first
thing that will delve into is giving you
sort of an overlay of the narrative
Universe including the conflicts that
are set up and why people are out there
in between the Stars jumping from point
to point and carrying on this very
interesting kind of Lifestyle with all
sorts of ramifications so sit back we
got a lot of cool stuff coming up and
let's jump right into talking about
world building
it strikes me that if we're thinking
about these four merchanter novels in
particular set in the alliance Union
universe
we absolutely have to look at the back
story and the development up to that
point and the we could say new cultures
that are being developed over the course
of that time and history so we're going
to do a little bit of backtracking you
could find quite a bit of this sort of
sketched out for yourself in down below
station which we're not going to talk
about here but there's also websites
where you can easily find this this
summarized as well we're interested in
this is a rich background for these
particular novels which is also going to
be developed further through each of
these novels each of them you could
think of as giving us like not just a
glimpse into here's here's you know one
place that we haven't talked about
before sort of like Ursula the green
when she's talking about Earthsea she
would say well you know I had the map
and I would think well what's happening
over in avnor or Palm I have to write a
story about that in a way it is kind of
like Le guin's Earthsea in that nothing
well except for we could say a few uh
you know exceptions to this some of the
short stories and um arguably tahanu
none of it takes place just in one
island or in the case of cherished stuff
in one planet one space station one ship
or anything like that instead we've got
going between places so enough of that
let's let's talk about what happened so
this is set in a future to our own time
in which mankind has gone out to the
Stars it's taken hundreds and hundreds
of years and it wasn't an immediate oh
well we ran into the Vulcans and they
gave us warp drive and now we're off to
the races or anything like that it was a
long long laborious process and so it
begins with Earth First you know
exploring the solar system and being
able to set up uh colonies and stations
within that area you know mining
asteroids that that sort of business and
then going out to some of the nearest
stars and as we're going to see chair is
setting this in a realistic
star map we'll talk about that in just a
bit as well
so the very first ships that go out are
slower than the speed of light and you
know it's going to take lots and lots of
time to get out there Earth starts to
send these Pusher ships as they're going
to be called in Alliance rising out to
you know carry materials and you can't
just like crash land on a planet and
begin colonizing in immediately first
you build these space stations and the
you know quickest that they begin
building are those that are close to
Earth and this takes decades and Decades
of bringing the materials the cores of
the space stations and then settling
them there and then colonizing those
with human beings from the solar system
as they begin to do this
the the company that's in charge of this
is called the Earth company right and
they're essentially running the show
they're in charge of everything but the
distances are pretty vast
and information doesn't travel any
faster than these these ships and the
Earth company is already starting to
lose a bit of its control over things
and then they try to you know clamp down
as well and they start developing
stations going further and further out
so that you can go you know you can use
instead of building everything on Earth
you can begin to build things on these
stations orbiting stars or planets and
um they build the next ones and the next
ones and the next ones and pretty soon
you've got a whole string of these
things and then they go all the way out
to two really really important
planets there's sighting which is going
to be colonized eventually and that will
actually become the Hub of what will be
called you and we'll get to that in a
bit
that's getting pretty far out the hit
you know hinder Stars the far out places
that take forever to get to but they
also find a Planet at Pell uh we're down
below station is is going to be set
right and
um there not only do they have a planet
that's more or less compatible with
human life you do have to wear like a
breathing mask because the spores will
mess you up but but there's intelligent
life the hissa the a race of alien
beings who work together with human
beings
and you can grow crops
you can grow foodstuffs not just
hydroponically not just you know
synthesizing things actual farming
taking place so now we've got humankind
spread all over the place
and then they discover faster than light
travel now this is not like you know FTL
stuff in many other series it messes you
up you have to take drugs tranquilizers
tranques if you don't want to be you
know turned inside out both uh in your
brain and perhaps even bodily to some
extent and it takes a toll as a matter
of fact another thing that's coming up
in this is you know as you're
approaching the speed of light you are
going out of the timeline of other
people you're aging at a different rate
and the FTL jump thing makes it even
more so
so we've got the you know on a technical
level on an economic level you know this
development going out to the stars and
uh the faster than light travel
is going to turn trips that would take
years and years into taking
months or even weeks
and that radically changes everything
because the
Earth company is losing more and more
control over what's happening out in
these distant systems where human beings
are and eventually these distant systems
particularly oriented around cyten are
going to break away and become a counter
Force called Union and Union uh you know
they don't have as many people as Earth
does they don't have quite the resources
that Earth does at first and Earth is
actually going to build an entire fleet
of 50 carrier ships to go and force the
rule of take back the the colonies that
are splitting off the stations and
colonies that are becoming part of the
Union Union uh resorts to cloning and
several other kinds of interesting
technology that will even the score and
there's going to be a huge huge war
between the the Earth company Fleet and
the fleet and other operatives you know
spies stuff like that that are um
defending the union planets and it's
going to be in some respects a war of
long attrition
meanwhile while all of this fighting is
going on and stations occasionally
they're being destroyed and ships are
being destroyed
um there is going to be two really
Central developments and we get to this
by the time of down below station which
again not not one of the books that
we're talking about here but it's part
of the back story for all of these
things that are happening
so on the one side we've got Earth and
we've got
um the union and Pell station is still
officially allied with Earth and the
merchants who go back and forth you know
they're getting preyed upon both by the
uh Earth uh Colony Fleet right and by
the union Fleet and they don't like that
either so what's going to end up
happening is the formation
of a new third power Alliance which is
going to be
focused or centered on Pell station but
include a whole bunch of other stations
that are that are uh not in Union
territory and break away from Earth
becoming part of this third Force
meanwhile
what else ends up happening the Earth
fleet has been decimated by losses and
they've also built up a lot of ill will
by taking people off of merchant vessels
and impressing them turning them
effectively into
new fodder for the war and uh maslon
decides he's the commander of the fleet
he decides that he's going to do
something
daring and different he's going to go
and take the fleet back to Earth
and Conquer Earth
this is the main Fleet for earth right
meanwhile Earth has been building some
defenses and things like that because
the the war hasn't been going well and
the fleet is not getting the support
from the earth company for decades now
that they felt that they they should
have
we also have one of his best captains
Sigourney Mallory who
um breaks away
and she
joins the alliance she fights against
the rest of the fleet and against the
Union
at Pell defending pal station
joining her
is also
a whole bunch of merchants including the
armed Merchant vessel affinity's end
very very important and so what we've
got now are four different factions we
have Earth and the Earth company we have
Union furthest out in between them we
have Alliance and off somewhere else
because they don't manage to take over
Earth is the remnants of mozlan's Fleet
the maslani who are pirates now who are
preying on everybody and there are
merchants on all different sides many of
them are part of the alliance many of
them are chartered in Union territory
and go back and forth from Alliance
Union or even all the way to Earth some
of them are double dealing working with
the Pirates and so we've got this very
complex
tapestry in which all of these forces
and we could really say that there's
essentially five different groups again
we've got Earth Union Alliance maslani
Pirates and then we have the other
Merchants who decide where they're going
to fit in they may be registered in
Alliance but not super happy about
supporting it you know they're all
trying to make a profit another thing
that we have to point out that's going
to be incredibly important particularly
in well
really in in almost all of these novels
although less so in Rim runners
but definitely Central to tri-point to
affinities and and in a different way to
merchanders lock
is that a lot of these ships are family
ships
the merchanters
sometimes you know are going to have
ships that are as big as a thousand crew
members like you know affinity's end at
his chart or Dublin again
in merchander's luck but there's also
the you know ships like the cygnus
going under the the guise of the the
Lucy
in merchander's luck and so
because
there's this time differential and
because living on a ship is so
culturally and experientially different
than living on a station or living on
Earth or on a planet or something like
that
these ships are going to become their
own little
microcosm their own little culture a
place where they have their own laws and
Norms governing them some of them take
on people who aren't from their family
and bring them into their their ship and
make them part of it as we find in
TriPoint
others don't welcome Outsiders right and
they will stick up for each other as
we're going to find out in finity's end
and there's all sorts of very
interesting wrinkles that we're going to
explore there so I think this probably
gives you enough backstory World
building for all of the other things
that we're going to discuss with these
four novels I think after discussing
chera's own remarks about her her work
and what other people have said we might
also talk about each of these novels for
briefly and what's distinctive to them
who the main characters are how the
world is being
unpacked revealed referenced in each of
these and what side these different
people characters groups families
factions are actually on and who they're
serving
as I was digging around online I did
find several excerpts from various sites
one from an interview one from an
acceptance speech and one from a review
that I wanted to bring up at this point
and talk about a little bit in part
because they do have to do with World
building and character and plot
development and also with the nature of
these particular merchanter novels so in
The Amazing Stories interview
chera is asked your alliance Union
universe is stretched across an entire
Library shelf captivating the
imagination of so many for those who are
not familiar with your alliance Union
please describe to us the universe and
what we can find there and here's what
she says that I think is really
interesting
Alliance Union is a future history for
which I literally made on sheets of
glass and finally on computer a real map
of the real stars surrounding our solar
system places like Alpha and beta
Centauri epiri taucetti Etc and figured
out how we could use certain real places
as a set of Stepping Stones to the Stars
I worked out how and humanly why you
could have an Interstellar civilization
with nine ships and where that would
lead it led in the stories to people who
wanted to be free of Earth's influence
those that wanted to preserve it and
those that wanted to trade between them
and belong to neither
it led to the evolution of a new kind of
mindset and the colonization of more
places and ultimately to contact with
more than one other intelligence so just
in that paragraph answer so much packed
in there so much to unpack
so the first thing the alliance Union is
a future history it's not as it's
sometimes described Space Opera it's not
just hard science fiction it is intended
to be a future history a possibility for
us human beings much like some of the
other sci-fi authors and series that
we've looked at in the worlds of
speculative fiction it's not just saying
let's tell a great story I got to do
some World building it's actually here
we get to the second Point chera says I
looked at the star Maps I looked at what
is actually at least in potentiality
feasible for us earth-based human beings
first we colonize our solar system and
then we go out to the nearest stars and
it's going to take us a while to get
there and then from there we can begin
building our way outward and I like that
she calls these set of Stepping Stones
to these stars and then she says this is
really important I worked out how but
why the philosophical question the
question of motivation why would we go
out to the stars and some people might
say well because they're there that's
not enough for people who are going to
leave behind everybody that they know
and go way the hell out there and become
part of some sort of colony or space
station and spend the rest of their life
isolated from where they originally came
and then I like this other this other
thing that she points out which we're
going to see her talking about in other
places
people who wanted to be free of Earth's
influence okay so there later on we're
going to have the union but also to some
degree Alliance right and uh we might
even say
the maslani in some respect and those
who wanted to preserve Earth's influence
right Earth obviously some of the
members of what would later become the
alliance uh the Earth Fleet before it
eventually becomes the the you know
Pirates and then those who wanted to
trade between them and belong to neither
Alliance but also all these Merchants
doing things in Alliance and Union and
Earth space and even trading with the
maslani as well
and then the last thing
um the evolution of a new kind of
mindset the colonization of more places
and contact with more than one other
intelligence the possibility of
encountering alien intelligent life and
engaging with them
um this is a very interesting set of
features of her work uh this the
interview goes on again and they ask
another question World building is
discussed and debated at conventions on
blogs and in books many point towards
your works as examples of masterful
World building how did you go about
constructing the alliance Union universe
what aspects of it still remain hidden
in your mind that have not yet found a
published page and so chaira then says
along with the star map and I'm
delighted to find Galactic mapping has
become a strong focus of modern
astronomy if I could have found such
maps at the time I would have turned
handsprings
I have a 5
000 year future history in a notebook
that shows me the parallel between
certain stories when and where they're
taking place and that sometimes suggests
what might be going on in a third place
I know events in that timeline that
rather cry out for a story so you know
we've talked about this many times in
the past when it comes to World building
sometimes people like to bring up this
distinction that uh George R Martin uh
put out there by describing himself by
contrast to J.R Tolkien Tolkien is an
architect Tolkien builds not only a
world and a back story but also
languages and ways of life and all of
those sorts of things whereas Martin
said I'm a gardener I plant a bunch of
seeds and I see which of them actually
come up and maybe do a little bit of
weeding and watering and harvesting but
I'm not like building everything out in
the way that a Tolkien does this implies
that chera
is a little bit more on the tokeny
architect side isn't she but Chara is
also somebody who works with
collaborators including her great friend
and then companion right so there is a
very interesting
set of speeches acceptance speeches to
the libertarian futurist society that
you can find on the Prometheus blog and
I'm just going to give you chera's
speech and only part of it actually so
she says again she's talking about World
building I was a little daunting I began
with a star map not a fictitious star
map but a real one of the Stars closest
to the Sun I started a map and my
calculation of roots with the help of an
Atari computer now that's going way way
back right Atari people don't really
remember this except you know if they're
of my age or older actually had a home
computer not just the Atari console for
playing games but an actual computer
that you could buy it was kind of high
priced compared to say Radio Shack you
know the TSR stuff or some of the other
ones but it existed and she had one
she says I worked out a route with the
realm of advanced possibility but a lot
of real astronomy has intervened in the
last several decades
I had to ask if all or any of my real
places were still viable in the way I
imagined or if we'd found things that
made it all impossible
no not so if anything we knew more
fascinating stuff I just took notes and
Jane and I claiming a booth at our
favorite Pub began plotting our waiters
understand us we took to the road
Seattle and back taking notes all the
way we have our ways of working we laid
out a basic scenario based on hints
given an already published books James
Robert had to be involved that was first
this is talking about a new novel at the
time Jane created some characters I
created others and we began to figure
our way to a crisis we do have
characters which are ours in a sense as
for how we work it's back and forth one
works a scene the other reworks and
Carries On to a new scene which then
goes back to the other honestly neither
of us can tell looking at a given
paragraph who wrote what now I'm going
to pause there for a minute because what
this brings to mind to me is the
collaborative writing of two other
really great science fiction writers
Catherine L Moore and Henry Kutner both
of whom published independently of the
other but who edited each other's Works
gave suggestions they were married
actually Jane and and CJ Chara are our
partners and
um eventually there are some pieces
where it's listed as being by Henry
Kutner but we're not sure if it's not
actually by CL Moore or a combination of
both and vice versa
so this is actually quite an interesting
observation about collaborative work
coming back to it
um she says when you've edited when
you've both edited something a dozen
times it all blurs into one I can claim
The Pusher ships that's a part of the
backstory though ironically we don't
ever see one and uh Ross is pretty much
entirely Jane's doing we needed him the
stations the merchanters the EC those
were set in published Stone why because
they're parts of these already
established novels that are there in the
storyline she says I've written books
about down below sighting and individual
merchanters like merchanters luck
Infinities and the development of
Warships and the aftermath of the war
but the scope of Alliance Rising is
different this is a story of all the
merchanters the merchant ships of the
future the descendants of The Pusher
ships which used to serve the stations
traveling for decades between Port calls
the former Crews have become family and
the ships have become family ships
unique in language and culture but
equally well needing the stations and
Hauling cargo the foundation of
everything that thrives save a couple of
ancient Pusher ships linking the first
Station Alpha to Earth and soul for all
their unique cultures they share a
universal language
trade very important point right there
then she goes on and she says
a small group of merchanders from the
ends of known space arrive at Alpha with
a proposal to the station and the
merchanders it's the merchanders who
have collectively the economic power to
keep individual ships going it's the
merchants who can keep information
flowing because it moves faster than
their ships it's the merchanders who
keep the goods flowing for the benefit
of the stations and themselves they
don't need the Earth company EC to tell
them how to do what they've already done
and they don't need to pay it for the
privilege it's an idea that is spreading
wherever ships go and serving notice to
the stations as well we'll haul for you
and you keep us running a basic deal a
fair deal no law on our decks as the
song has it but the law we have made
this is very interesting we're seeing a
philosophical theme right there right
what is it to be free it is to live
under laws that you yourself have made
and ratified an idea that we might get
from a manual con goes way back right
all the way back you could say to
Aristotle but it's also equally
pronounced in somebody like Rousseau
going on she says it's not so much that
we set out to write a novel about the
link between freedom and economics but
that when you start telling a story
about human civilization it goes with
the territory
early on Interstellar economics is
pretty simple the company Builds an
outpost using a Station Court built-in
Soul system pushed out to the Stars via
The Pusher ships man's it with Personnel
also trucked out from Earth pays those
employees with life Essentials and
luxury goods also from Good Old Mother
Earth with Earth Min a minimum of a
20-year Voyage away during which all
your friends back on the station would
Age a lot faster than you those
employees basically sign on to the
station for life they marry have 2.5
Offspring who grow up and work for the
Earth company because there's not a lot
of options
this is very important here though each
station becomes its own little island
eventually the essential setup of the
station is done and individuals are left
with spare time time to produce unique
Goods with those raw materials that can
actually be traded to others on the
station in exchange for station credit
to buy more luxury items from Earth so
the simple economy begins to get a
little less simple when those locally
made Goods begin to flow to the other
stations in the chain to taucetti the
web gets pretty Tangled the real chaotic
element which makes the economy linking
these three distinct groups the stations
Earth and the truckers or ships
interesting enough to become the
character that is an alliance Rising
begins with the truckers the sublight
crews refuse to retire and be replaced
because of time dilation of near light
speeds attained in the Voyages they have
become completely out of sync with both
Earth and the stations they dock at
their entire lives become centered on
the ship itself and all they really need
is fuel and supplies to get them to the
next port
she goes on and says a lot more but you
know some of this is matters we've
already covered in the world building
and future history stuff that we just
recalled a few minutes ago there is one
thing I also want to bring up and this
is coming from the alexandrian a
four-part review of The Alliance Union
merchanter novels so
it begins with merchanter's luck and
again I'm just taking excerpts here but
I think this is a really good set of
reviews
merchanter's lock is at its heart a
character drama a poignant powerful
poignant character drama you could call
it a Romeo and Juliet for the future but
that would only give you the most
grotesque approximation of what this
story is about what you get to see are
two characters brought together who
fundamentally change each other's lives
it's not easy it's not simple but it's
human
Chira has the rare gift of being able to
Bear a character's soul to the reader
and she uses that talent to great effect
here reading merchanter's luck is like
watching two brightly burning Stars
plunging one into the other each searing
you with the heat of their existence
it's an intense and Primal reality that
Chara shows you
the next one Rim Runners Joe Walton
describes chera's uni Alliance Union
Union Alliance novels as historical
fiction there's a lot of Truth to that
every novel is set across a small slice
of a backdrop that stretches for decades
and light years in every direction with
each novel you read in the union
Alliance sequence your understanding of
that historical backdrop deepens and
each individual's work becomes even more
faceted as a result the reflections it
Cass on the others not telling us a lot
about the plot or characters of Rim
Runners but we'll get to that in a bit
try point
chair excels at capturing utterly
diverse points of view with truthfulness
and integrity her characters don't see
things differently because some of them
are stupid or naive or ignorant although
some of them are and she doesn't go in
for any of these cheats
her characters see things differently
because they are fundamentally different
people and that's pretty impressive
because there just aren't that many
authors who are capable of that even at
their best at chera effortlessly
accomplishes it with every novel given
this unique strength tri-point is
particularly interesting because it's
fundamentally the story of a character
caught between two utterly different
points of view one embodied by his
mother the other embodied by his father
and the catalytic events which force him
to find his own compromise and synthesis
between those dichotomous poles
a lot of her work seem to have identity
as a central theme her characters are
driven often compulsively by the
questions of who am I and who do I want
to be
unsurprisingly many of her stories are
also Tales of adolescence and that's a
place where TriPoint exists
affinity's end
another tale of adolescence and identity
in many ways the central character
dramas of TriPoint Infinities end are
very similar to each other both take a
young protagonist from one environment
and thrust them into another forcing
them to adapt and find a new identity
for themselves
but they're the similarity essentially
ends not only are the individual
characters so unlike each other as to
result in completely different stories
but the plots against which their
character arcs are silhouetted are
fundamentally different
tri-point is a Space Opera of pirates
and privateers affinity's end is a
political drama
concluding thoughts of that review
as exemplaries are as any of these
novels are in their own rights I was
particularly impressed by the strength
they draw from each other chair never
allows her plot to exist without
impacting her characters nor does she
allow her characters to exist without
affecting her setting
as a result the more you learn of the
Union Alliance Universe the more depth
each novel in the series possesses it
follows that I must someday soon come
back to these novels and read them again
the ever-shifting ever-growing context
of chairs work gives each novel a fresh
perspective and existence when viewed in
each other's light somewhere in the
interstice of these four novels lies and
understanding of what it means to be a
merchander plying the interstellar Lanes
that's such an understanding is never
spelled out or given a pithy summary
makes it all the more meaningful and
true
it is an understanding crafted by cherub
but wrought in your own imagination
and there's just one word I want to pick
up on as we bring this little section of
talking about shara's own Reflections
and other people's Reflections on our
work that true
how is it
that's something that is clearly fiction
set within a fictional universe
conveys truth well this I think is one
of the philosophical themes that we
absolutely
must explore
but I don't know that we can actually
embrace it theoretically head on we may
have to work at it from several
different angles
before we delve into some of the key
philosophical themes of these great
merchanter novels I think it's important
that we probably talk a little bit about
the characters and the key plots and
settings for each of these in turn so
the first of them is merchanter's luck
and then we have Rim Runners then we
have TriPoint and finally bringing up
the end Infinities end so let's look at
each of these in turn
this one merchanters luck is very
interesting it's you could say a tale of
two ships and in some respect a tale of
two characters and it begins their names
were sandor and Allison craya and Riley
respectively Riley meant something in
the offices and bars of Viking station
it meant the merchanders of the great
ship Dublin again based get far gone
respectable haulers on a loop that
included all the circle of Union Stars
Mariner and Russell's Esperance and
Paradise why it's in sighting far gone
and Voyager and back to Viking
it was a name among merchanters and a
power to be considered wherever it went
craya meant nothing at Viking having
flourished only at distant pan Paris and
Esperance in its day at Mariner under an
alias it meant a bad debt and the same
at Russell's the crayoship was currently
named Lucy and she was supposedly based
at Wyatt's was which was as far away as
possible and almost farther away than
reasonable for such a small and aged
freighter claiming to run margin cargo
for a Wyatt's combine so what we've got
going on there is a vast contrast we
have sandor Crea who is piloting what's
now called The Lucy which was before
that the Cigna and this is a very old
ship it's kind of small and it was
originally a family merchandership but
as we are going to find out all of his
family are dead and this is part of the
legacy of the the come company Wars and
their outcome the Mazatlan uh you know
he's not quite sure which ship it was at
first because he has to try to remember
this one of the carriers
boarded with Marines the ship and as
they were accustomed to do they took all
the good stuff and they actually
killed just about everybody on the ship
except for sandor and two of his
relatives both of whom by the time this
begins are dead the Dublin again is one
of the massive Merchant ships and as we
see it is cycling around in Union
territory although it's making stops as
well at Pell and considering getting
involved in the earth trading as well
and we find that sandor is going to fall
in love with Allison Riley and you know
she's from this very important
merchanter ship where she's got lots and
lots of cousins lots of support
but she's also way way way down the line
of succession and they wind up having an
overnight that's what we nowadays call a
hookup it's called an overnight when you
do it on space stations as uh you know
people who are are spending their time
on ships and they get involved with each
other and then something really
interesting happens so sandor is strung
out both physically and mentally he's
trying to run things on his own and he
wants to follow the Dublin again to Pell
and he makes a crazy set of jumps and
we'll talk about the nature of jumps a
little bit later which makes him kind of
a minor celebrity
and when they run into each other
they become involved again and
interestingly
um the Dublin again is willing to extend
credit and protection to sandor and the
erstwhile Lucy and the reason they're
willing to do this is not just to like
break in on a new commercial territory
and it's not just because they're
willing to send a small bit of their
crew to help out with sander who doesn't
trust them immediately including Allison
once she gets on his ship it's also
because the
alliance Battleship or rather carrier
run by Mallory is also involved and
they're going to use this ship the Lucy
to flush out some of the Mazatlan forces
including an entire carrier that's going
to show up and interestingly once they
get on the ship and by there I mean the
Dublin again crew comprised of four
members
they're going to discover that the ship
is actually in many respects mysterious
and sealed off
in part because
sander doesn't want to go to these parts
of the ship where his family was living
and there are entire you know areas that
are just left the way they are he also
won't give them the codes until later on
and there's like a standoff between them
until they get to the space station and
all hell breaks loose they wind up being
boarded by the Muslim forces
sandor and one of the other crew are
taken to the station and interrogated
and then the Cavalry
proverbably shows up and winds up saving
them and where we're left at the very
end of this book is with sandor having
given Allison the codes he wrote them
down and put them in his dresser and
she's able to save the other crew
members and then they begin begin their
business again but now with a lot behind
them so that's that's the first of these
interesting ones then we get a total
departure from this in Rim Runners and
you notice it's got this you know rather
athletic uh woman with short hair
running in this uh this deck area and
she is the main character of this story
Elizabeth or bat Yeager who is
originally
a marine sergeant
and she has been pretending to be
somebody different than that somebody
who can do mechanical work and she got
left behind
um during the time of the company War so
she has had to go under disguises for
quite a long time and we meet her here
stuck on Thule uh rather decrepit broken
down station
and she's got this this um identity
worked up for herself Yeager Elizabeth a
machinist freighter 20 years born to a
hired spacer on the freighter Candide
citizenship Alliance age 37 education
level 10 no relatives previous
employment various ships in system or
maintenance Pell and she's trying to
find a ship to get on but Thule is way
the hell out in the middle of nowhere
and she's been there for nearly a year
and she gets involved in some problems
again sort of like the the previous
character and Merchant there's luck
getting close to the end of her
resources both psychologically and
physically and also monetarily and she
winds up getting involved with first she
ends up killing a man in a bathroom
who's trying to assault her then she
gets involved with this bartender who
then tries to blackmail her and she ends
up killing him as well well and now she
definitely needs to get off that station
so she is going to sign on to a ship and
she has to find a way to fit herself
into
the culture of that ship and she she
does she gets onto the Loki
and the Loki's doing some kind of weird
stuff it's supposed to be a you know a
merchantorship uh it's not a family
merchandership it hires crew here and
there and they come on board
um but it's not what you could call you
know using this term that we see here an
honest freighter right they're actually
um a ship that is engaged in some skull
dodgery we could say and they're they're
doing all sorts of interesting stuff
selling information
and there's a lot of politics on this
ship and she gets herself involved with
a guy who goes by the name NG no good
he's kind of messed up he was he was a
screwed up character to begin with but
he also had to undergo a jump without
tranquilizers and that did a number on
him as well and they are going to wind
end up at a space station just as a
maslon carrier is coming in and this
will allow her to you might say rise to
the occasion reveal who she is use her
former Marine training against the
people who she used to work with the now
turned Pirates maslani so that's a you
know another interesting story about a
person you could say finding their way
and we have a similar third story in the
longer try point where we have a guy who
you could say is caught between
two families two ships
two inner worlds and so
We Begin by looking at this ship the
Sprite I'll just mention that this is a
good line 200 ship years old Sprite was
not a big ship not as old as Dublin uh
or affinities and not a glamor ship no
long runs no memorable action and the
war just a light armed hard worker that
kept the goods moving and delivered the
heartbeat of civilization where she made
port and the information of her last
port flowed into the current ports data
on banks stock reports trade figures
births and deaths books entertainments
news and inventions across the web of
stars the tick and pulse of everything
human was in Sprites data banks when she
docked and so this is another important
ship and the captain is currently Misha
Hawkins and
um
uh you know there there's uh Thomas
Hawkins who is his nephew and then we
find out that he is the product
of a rape on one of these overnights and
his father is Austin Beau and we hear
about another ship the Corinthian right
Austin Beau was Corinthian senior
Captain Misha and Marie kept current
using dioxide sources he didn't have
Marie is uh the mother of
um
the the main character here Tom and so
what we're going to see is these two
ships wind up in the same place at the
same time this rarely happens
but it does happen and Marie goes out
looking for some sort of Revenge and the
Revenge that she's going to get largely
involves figuring out what the
Corinthian is up to she knows that
they're not an honest freighter they're
doing something somewhere and she goes
out looking for them and her son goes
along as well and is
um you know going to try to keep her out
of trouble and perhaps
um you know find some things out for
himself as well and what ends up
happening is Tom Hawkins gets caught
going through the Corinthian and
essentially
impressed into the crew and this is very
interesting because he has a younger
brother who is
um you know a half brother really who is
an important officer in the crew and now
that he's on that ship well he's the son
of the captain but he also doesn't quite
fit in he's kind of an enemy and these
are enemies to him but he has to become
a member of this crew and there's a lot
of back and forth a lot of fighting a
lot of Adventures happening some
loyalties he meets a really strong guy
who works in the galley named Tink
becomes friends with him winds up having
a romantic interest and eventually
interestingly the two ships now
especially since Marie you know she's
very smart very resourceful she makes an
argument for following the Corinthian to
the the same place now on the way the
Corinthian is going to be revealed as
once sort of like in the rim Runner the
Loki doing some stuff that's not quite
on the up and up right
they're actually helping to supply
the now pirate maslani Fleet as do some
others as well we're going to see that
coming up again in finity's end too and
so this winds up you know a very complex
set of subplots and in the end Tom finds
his place and finds his way and he's not
going to come back to
his original ship or to his mother
who now is the captain of the Sprite
right and we see a different sort of
resolution and even some hints that the
maslani have found a place to settle out
there in the stars and perhaps even can
build up their own new power base
we finally have finity's end and
finity's end is the name of a ship as
well as of a book and finity's end is
one of the oldest of the merchanderships
it's also one of the greatest of them it
is along with uh Mallory and her Norway
the ships that have been the backbone of
the alliance around Pell and of the
merchanters so they've been fighting
Warfare but they also suffered some
terrible losses in fact an entire
generation of children and many of their
parents as well so they're under crude
and we begin
with this character who has been stuck
on pal station and going down below
for years and years and years now down
down below
um actually has these aliens called the
hisa or down belowers who are working
sometimes on the station and this young
really man you can say because he's
around 17 years old at this point uh
Fletcher he has become
friends and you know even you could say
intimate of some of them and he he
doesn't want to have anything to do with
the ship finity's end but they come to a
legal decision about this and he has to
report back to the affinities and then
we see all sorts of interesting legal
Maneuvers let me just read you
this so
um
two legal papers waited Ellen Quinn's
signature and the matter pending before
the court of Pell in the final
settlement of the afore said claim
against the merchant ship finities and
James Robert neihart senior Captain
finity's end her crew and Company tender
000 credits to be held in escrow against
all charges whatsoever of and whatever
origin public or private as of the state
pending set amount to be placed in Bank
of Pell to clear all debts of Fletcher
Robert Nyhart a national
affinity's end he belongs to that ship
right he's a citizen of that ship and
he's had to live with foster parents
since his mother committed suicide when
he was quite Young
debt paid Affinity Zen simply sent the
agreed amount to the bank of Pelham a
legal dispute that had troubled all
affinity's wartime dockings was done
with further claims and debts of any
sort would be judged against that 150
000 uh credit fund uh it focused the
political in Fighters and their lawyers
on a single achievable prize not a kid
and his surrounding issues
so he winds up having to go on to
finity's end and find again we see a
common theme here having to find a way
in there of course he runs away before
this and gets close to dying because uh
you know the world that down below of
Pell station there's you have to wear
respirators and things like that but
they they do get him and now he is
trying to
get away from them if he can but also
trying to figure out where he fits in
and there's a lot going on
including some of the people
tricking him treating him badly him
fighting also against them and then we
have us this incredibly important
precipitating matter
he is allowed to bring an artifact from
the hisa which was given to him by the
most senior of them when he ran away
onto the ship
it winds up being stolen I won't tell
you who stole it because I'd like you to
read the text itself I will say this
it leads effectively to we might say an
international incident or the equivalent
of that in merchander space between the
different factions and the different
ships and finity's end the captain is
not only trying to take finity's end
back to away from military matters back
to civilian matters and trading
they're also trying to fare it out this
network of traders merchanders who are
supplying the maslani fleet and this is
happening in part in Alliance space but
also in Union space and in other places
as well and so the artifact being stolen
and then being found again uh
particularly uh because it's it's
involved with the crew of a ship that
they've been following who wound up
stealing it and selling it is going to
lead to a new configuration of power and
by the end we find that Fletcher has
himself become an effective part of his
ship his homeland so to speak of
finity's end so we have some interesting
common themes as you hear me recall this
you notice
character arcs of somebody who
is in a bad situation doesn't really fit
in but has had to come up with an Mo for
their life being thrown into new
situations figuring out how to deal with
the people that they're involved with
involved in larger plots and
machinations and having to find a place
for themselves and I think that is
really one of the key themes of all of
these merchanter novels and you'd I'll
say this as a last thing we are getting
into philosophical themes here
to find a place for yourself isn't to
find a place alone
lonely solitary and it's not just to
lose yourself
in a crew it's to form important
relationships and not just one very
often there are love relationships in
quite a few of these
but it's also relationships of
friendship and relationships of
comradeship and Affinity in many cases
family as well trust has to be built and
earned and tried in order for these
characters
to develop and even come to the point of
we might say
flourishing finding out who they are
within a matrix of always vulnerable
relationships so that's a good summary
and we've already started getting into
some of the philosophical themes so now
let's look at some of the other
philosophical themes in more detail
in CJ chairs Alliance Union Universe
novels one of the things that we find is
a very interesting feature of the ways
in which human beings have to live out
there in the stars is the jump the jump
into hyperspace traveling from point to
point and one of the main features of
this is you have to actually be able to
carry out calculations and set things up
so that you can jump and you need mass
that you can Orient yourself around this
is why TriPoint winds up being such an
important juncture point and not
everybody knows exactly where all of the
masses are so we see that there's a
character for example in discussed in
TriPoint who is a former Fleet Navigator
and she's got got all this stuff up in
her head and because of that she's she's
a wanted person we're more interested
less than that Intrigue we'll talk about
some of that later but more in what it
is that jump involves and what it does
to human beings so it's not like in all
these these stories and movies and TV
shows where you just go let's go to warp
or let's go to hyperspace and the Stars
suddenly change and you're in one place
and then you go to another place
it takes a massive toll on human beings
and so maybe one of the places to begin
is with finities and and Fletcher
because he has to experience this for
the first time and interestingly
his mother was stranded on Pell
affinity's end didn't show up to pick
her up and she actually overdosed
herself on the drug that they have to
take and so this is a really Central
feature of jumping if you go through it
without taking the tranquilizers you're
going to have problems as we'll see a
little bit later on so this is uh the
very first encounter discussing this
um
Jr is coming by and saying you know you
need to have tranquilizers and he says
jump drugs it's a regulation you have
them on you at all times you didn't
report to infirmary when you boarded
they were inevitability staring him in
the face the event he most dreaded why
because his mother had died because of
them nobody told me fine I'm telling you
now for all future time scared to give
yourself a shot no he'd never done it
but he'd watched it you just put it
against your wrist and push the button
kicks if you have one malfunction they
don't but if it should happen you're
supposed to have a second whenever you
use one you've got to drop by medical
that's a 10 day before jump they'll
always be a box sitting out for you to
take what you need one packet on your
person at all times when the ship is out
of dock and extra when you're going for
jump and so you notice that this is part
of the equipment
of any space farer right the people who
are traveling on these Merchant ships
but also it would apply to Fleet ships
as well
so then he says there's three this time
yes try points supposedly safe as a
dioxide stroll these days but nobody on
this ship would bet his Sanity on it a
jump points a lot of dark where you can
still meet somebody you don't want to
meet and if we do if we should you'll
hear the siren blowing when you come out
of jump and you'll have just enough time
to hit yourself with that second shot
you've got to keep clear-headed and do
that or you're in serious trouble not to
scare you but this ship has enemies and
people have gone into hyperspace without
tranq but most don't come down the way
they went in
and so then he says when you board for
the record next thing after you turn in
your baggage at the dock the packets are
on the counter pick them up and he he
goes on right and he says pick up the
drugs sign the list so a little bit
later on they actually do jump and we
read an interesting account of what that
was like for the first time for Fletcher
and he goes there's a little um
remembering period where he talks about
or he's thinking about his time down
below
but we'll start here he pushed the
packet hard against his bare forearm the
spring kicked he didn't feel it as
sharply as he thought he should it
didn't sting he held the clear packet up
to his eye the plastic was flat against
the packing fluid depleted it had gone
in it looked as if it had maybe he
should take the other one in case maybe
he'd ejected on the bed clothes instead
of his arm
Fletcher did you do it are you all right
yes he was shivering but things were
growing distant he felt the drug
insinuating itself through his veins it
had gone in he'd just been so scared he
hadn't felt the sting he was getting
slower slower and lighter at the same
time maybe the ship had cut the engines
it felt that way we have that memory and
then uh we we hear Fletcher someone said
from outside and he blinked shaky sick
someone his eyes were blurred lifted his
head up after several tries and
succeeded after he began to cooperate
with the effort to lift him some would
put something to his lips and said drink
so he closed his lips on the straw and
drank it was what his body needed a
taste told him that that somebody was a
younger cousin Jeremy the place was the
ship the Army was holding himself up
with began to shake the place smelled
like sweat and old clothes something
wrong with the ship he found the
strength to panic and tried to sit up no
Jeremy said keep drinking the juice I'm
a senior by the month by a month I get
the shower first well did something
happen he called after Jeremy thinking
because it had been so short a time they
must have aborted the Run
but things had changed he felt his face
the little trace of beard dead skin that
rolled off under his fingers his clothes
were disgusting like month old laundry
the smell was him
we're at TriPoint Jeremy called back
from inside the shower drink the juice
you'll be sorry if you don't we're going
to be blowing velocity in a bit don't
panic if the ship sort of goes away it
just does that it's kind of wild about
two three times
he had three packets of the stuff he
drained the first there was a terrible
moment of giddiness where the deck
seemed to dissolve under him and the
walls went nowhere he was utterly
disoriented and slumped down in the bed
until the feeling went away
going on a little bit further that was
the first Jeremy called out damn that
was hard first what he felt sick at his
stomach V dump Jeremy yelled back there
was the sound of the shower breaking
hyperspace style we don't go up all the
way we just sort of brush it slows us
down
he knew something about hyperspace he'd
never imagined feeling it
they just touched the hyperspace
interface he felt shaky and ripped open
another Jews so thirsty his mouth felt
Dusty things tasted too sweet and too
sour the green Walls had a flavor the
smell had a color and not a pretty one
most of all the Dreadful thing had
happened he was no longer at Pell he was
out of the reach of home and the only
thing he could think of was a desperate
need for liquid and what taste told him
what was in that liquid he ripped open
another drink packet he sat there
sipping mineral reinforced juice until
Jeremy came out to look for a change of
clothes
going on a little bit more he felt like
hell and they were going to be working
and we we get you know an emergency
happening as well and so what do we see
in this little vignette
so when you travel through hyperspace
ranked up in the jump it seems like it
just takes a moment but you're actually
out of it
for a long time and this increases the
space the time space uh Distortion that
happens for those who are traveling
between the Stars it's one reason why
the merchanters become you could say
their own little subcultures associated
with their ships by comparison to the
people on the stations by comparison to
the people back at Earth
and so we have some other interesting
depictions as well and in Rim runners
we find out that uh Elizabeth or bet
um she winds up being so strung Out
close to the time that they do the first
jump that she realizes she can't go to
Medical she needs to get herself back up
to
um
you know some limited amount of health
or she's going to stand out too much now
there was an interesting reference to
what happens if you don't have the
tranquilizers when you go in to jump and
so we have this character NG which means
no good right that's his his nickname
and we hear something about this ship
that she is on and some of the people
and the rivals and factions going on
here
so um
here we go
Musa is telling that Jaeger about
something that
um Berenstein had done he says I think
one time the ship went jump or actually
uh Fitch rather the ship went jump and
NG was in the brig I'm not real sure
Fitch saw that he got his trank I'm not
sure I understand but that time
Bernstein got him off maybe it was just
one time too often in the brig maybe it
was that jump and looking that spacewalk
in the face but I'm not sure that didn't
happen just the way I said Fitch hates
his guts we had an emergency we had to
go to jump NG was dead the way Fitch had
to figure but once Bernstein got him
reprieved the other side of jump no way
was Fitch going to tell the captain what
he'd done can't prove it NG don't talk
I'm not real sure all of him came back
from that trip
God
not saying it's so understand no way to
prove it don't even think about it we're
legitimate now we're Alliance there's
rights and there's laws and the captain
sign on to them
but they aren't on this ship woman and
you don't get off this ship no way you
ever get a discharge from this crew I
hope you figured that when you signed
your name you skip on a dioxide Fitch
will find you you go to complain to
station law official lie and get you
back and you'll go on a cold walk that's
sure Fitch tell you that and so we we
see that NG has been you know damaged
goods in in many respects from uh the
effects on the human brain of taking a
jump through hyperspace without the
drugs that you need in order to make
that work we get some interesting things
also coming up in TriPoint now this is
with people who've done plenty of jumps
and are you know perfectly fine with it
so this is
um
the discussion about what else could be
going on in this uh you know
space there this time that you have to
your own where you might have visions
you might experience synesthesia of
sorts so
um
here we go uh
this is the way Marie had dealt with his
child as fancies made fun of them
sometimes fallen in with them she said
they were all right and then he goes on
and he's amusing him a bit more
sometimes often you felt a sexual dream
coming when you were falling in to Jump
Sykes psychologists like Aunt Lynn Lydia
always said don't do it particularly if
you aimed at being operational crew
because if you ever got into that habit
it happened too easily and you might not
come back in time to handle operations
addictive they said nothing about the
experiences was real of course except
your own side of the experience and that
felt very real when you were coming out
of hyperspace every representation the
sense is made the brain had to find some
symbol for so things would always appear
chaotic and it could be sex it could be
very good sex or for no reason at all it
could become a disturbing nightmare out
of symbols of brain started calling up
from some closet of the half awake mind
though sex was the most common so of
course if you were a stupid kid had
heard from his peers about fantastic
trips you tried flying that way a couple
times getting yourself off by the
time-tested methods until you scared
hell out of yourself at least once ended
up on deep drink for maybe the next two
trips and learned to do math problems
instead when you went null didn't want
to go into jump seeing the brig around
him didn't want to think about piracy
and ships getting blown didn't want to
ponder about Marie this was a deep deep
mental pit he didn't want to excavate on
this trip he tried equations tried
programming problems and he kept losing
them kept finding Fantastical bits of
nonsense running through his head
childhood Rhymes and Rodman's poetry
Tommy's a Corinthian Tommy's a
Corinthian lock him up with iron bars
iron bars and then throw away the key
London Bridge is falling down he goes on
with this as well and uh Aunt Lydia had
explained something you know about sex
and not thinking about it while they're
on trips so you know what do we find
here what you go into the state of being
tranquilized and then going into jump
which is not just about being on drugs
it's about going from you know one space
to another through hyperspace which is
profoundly weird on the brain
can have some pretty important
implications depending on what you're
thinking about a little bit later we're
you know in where we actually find out
about capella who knows about all these
Fleet drop points and they're trying to
find her we find out that Austin
Thomas's older brother or younger
brother rather the one who has been on
Corinthian this entire time and who's
who's got a leadership position
he was afraid of jump
he we we read this
never forgot those years the nerves had
still been there when he was 16 worse
maybe he'd only heard later what was
going on never so he could pin this
sensation to that movement Impressions
all muddled up in a three-year-old's
memory of five-year-olds Terror
for 16 17 years he had been spooked by
Jump by the g-forces by the whole
feeling of a ship doing what a ship did
but capella had laughed him through his
tears capella had snared him in other
Sensations taught him to enjoy the
craziness to see the dimensions as other
than up and down and falling Austin was
wrong about her capella had come to him
on the docks not the other way around
um
he and he goes on thinking you know he
could trust her with with his his life
and um so you know interesting
Revelation there about people being
afraid to jump and then I think that we
can't not discuss one of the really key
high points in merchander's luck with
somebody making some crazy jumps right
and this is because
um you know
this character uh sandor is in love with
Allison and wants to meet up with her
she is on a much bigger faster ship that
can go further in jumps he is alone and
he sets up a series of jumps that just
about kill him or could have easily
turned him insane right and so we read
here
he checked his calculations rechecked
and triple checked lining everything up
for an operation far more ticklish than
calculating around the aberrations of
Lucy's docking Jets no points move being
more than planet-sized mass in the
complicated motions of stars comp had to
allow for it no one sane would head into
jump alone with a comp computer that had
no backup with tranq and food and water
taped to the board he told himself so
making his prep darting glances back to
comp and scan listening to the buoy
beeping steadily watching them track
right down the line he put the tranq
into his arm it was about time for that
to dull the senses which were about to
be abused no one not one jump to face
but three
and if he missed on one of them as he
reckoned he would never know it now
here's a little bit more about uh what
goes on
there is speculation as to what what
what was to be strung out in the in
between and speculation about what the
human mind might start doing once the
drugs were off and there was no way back
there were tails of ships which wafted
in and out of jump like ghosts with
Eerie whales on the receiving calm damn
Souls that never came down and never
made port and never died in time that
never ended but those were drunken
fancies the kind of Legends which
wandered stationed oxides when Crews
were topping one another with pints and
horror Tails deliberately frightening
stationers and in-system spacers who
believed every word of such things
he did not above all want to think of
them now but he had little enough time
to do anything Hereafter but keep Lucy
tracking and keep his wits about him if
things went wrong if he made the
slightest error in calculation he could
spend a great deal of time at the first
null Point getting himself sorted out
and he could lose Dublin
the tranq was getting taking hold he
thought of Dublin behind him in the
hazard of it he reached for the calm
punched in narrow focused the
transmission a matter between himself
and the Sleek huge merchanter that came
on his tail Dublin this is U.S 48 335
why Lucy number one for jump advise you
boy is in error I'm Bound for pal repeat
buoy information is in air I'm Bound for
Pell don't crowd my departure
then we find out again
conscious again and still tranked hyper
in sedated at Once A peculiar
Coincidence of mental States in which he
was aware of alarms ringing and Lucy
doing her mechanical best tell to tell
him she was carrying dangerous residual
velocity the power it took to dump had
to be measured against the power it took
to acquire no dice throws calculate move
the arm punch the buttons dump the speed
down to the margin or lose the ship on
the next westons Point present location
in the appropriate jump range entry
proceeding towards dark and then we have
another jump as well he came out of
sleep with the push or the pulser
stinging his wrist and with an ache all
the way down to his heels unbelted and
leaned over the left side of the cushion
to dry heave for a moment collapsed in
that armrest weighing more than he
thought he should in carrying far less
about survival than he should because
he'd gone into this too tired with his
defenses too depressed and the tranq was
not wearing off he had to get something
to eat and drink because he was going
again in half an hour and that was too
little time and so we find that he's in
the middle of this Marathon right second
jump statistically better this time a
vast Point uh wake up Sandy the and then
we hear uh his own voice pre-recorded
the reference now is Pell's star push
the track reset Sandy the track reset
he was crazy that was what he swallowed
in mechanical on tasting gulps unable to
remember what buttons he'd pushed
trusting his own recorded voice giving
him the sequences of the comp needed
them trusting to that star he saw a
bracketed ahead of them him if it was
not a trick of mine which had come loose
in time
right and then we we find that he's
really strung out by the time that he
actually gets to palestar and then we
hear uh something really interesting
once he actually gets himself docked and
off of the ship first he has to discuss
something with a police officer Alliance
Security operations and then when he
gets through
um he finds out
from somebody puts a mic in his face you
know the whole station's been following
your calm for five hours Captain did you
know that no he stared helplessly
realizing his face his face recorded
made public with Lucy's name and number
I'm tired he said but the cam but the
microphone persisted thrust towards him
um and then they ask him some more
questions and uh eventually here we get
to it he says I just want to get to the
bank I didn't do anything you cleared a
viking to Pell in a month in a ship that
size solo what kind of rig is she excuse
me please you don't call what you did
remarkable the reporter asks I call it
stupid please he shoved through with
people surging all around him as heart
hammering and panic people people as far
as you can see and all of a sudden she
was there Allison Riley was straight in
front of him wide-eyed as the rest of
the crowd
you're crazy she said you're outright
crazy and then she takes them to the bar
gets some food in him uh some some you
know drinks and things like that uh and
then takes him for an overnight and she
uh shoves him down in the middle of his
chest and he nearly fell down idiot she
said to him which was not the welcome
he'd hoped for but what he reckoned now
he deserved he stood there paralyzed in
his misery in his mental state until she
pulled him over to the bed and pushed
him down on it she started working at
his clothes with rough abrupt movements
as if she were still Furious roll over
she hissed at him and pushed pulled at
his shoulder and threw the covers over
him and he fell asleep
so
quite a story there as well quite
romantic but you see the the centrality
of this experience of going out to the
Stars this is something that the
merchanters are going through fairly
routinely but you have to be initiated
into it and there are Terrors even for
those who understand what they're doing
because it's such a remains a foreign
experience and it's something that can
be planned for but it's also containing
all sorts of moments of the unforeseen
as well so this is a really important
feature I think something that Chara
depicts so well I've only read you a few
of the passages that many passages where
she discusses the effects of jump
through hyperspace on human beings
I've already exceeded the 90 minute mark
that I had set out for these videos as
sort of a goal so I don't want to go
overly long past that and thanks for
hanging around this far but I do want to
touch on one other majorly important
philosophical theme that I brought up
before and I've talked about trauma and
we can definitely say that dealing with
the
difficulties and the losses that one has
had imposed upon oneself is a major
theme a a problem that is set for really
all of these characters in these these
stories you know particularly
merchanders look we've got a ship that
you could say is is kind of a ghost
vessel right because
sandor has lost his entire family he's
closed off entire portions of the ship
it was raided by The masalani Pirates
Who took what they wanted killed just
about everybody and left just a few of
those and he's had to scrape by you know
counterfeiting and taking on
um all sorts of disguises changing the
patch the name of the ship claiming
things that are false and then he's
offered the chance of something like
legitimacy but it's not something he can
ease into right away and Trust as part
of the crew of Dublin again comes in
affinity's end we have all sorts of
interesting matters and um you know we
have uh
you know Fletcher is is dealing with the
loss of his mother the fact that the
ship that now he has to be a part of
didn't seem to want him for a long time
he's got to find his place in this and
then you know deal with losing his
connection with the down below where
he's uh aliens in Rim Runners we have
you know a middle-aged woman who has to
keep her identity a secret and I I'm not
going to read too much but I do want to
bring up just one part of this so she's
recalling her own
um history a fool kid had volunteered
herself onto Africa's deck volunteered
because Africa was going to take what
they wanted from the refinery ship at
pan Paris anyway which was always the
young ones and that was her better
choose she thought then because that way
you were a volunteer and that was points
on your record and because she hated her
life and hated the minds and she wanted
Starships more than she wanted anything
and the fool kid had found herself in
something she'd never remotely imagine
And The Fool kid had figured out damn
fast how not to be a fool the fleet
taught you that straight offer it broke
you and she was still alive the full kid
had gotten part of what she'd wanted she
still reckoned that had to be worth the
rest of it and still must be since she
just had her chance at station life and
here she was back again if it killed her
she thought right now it was like
something in her was back in connection
again and part of her was alive that
wasn't on station being out there on a
ship even a totally dysfunctional ship
like the one that she's on and we have
the the contrast in TriPoint
um you know between the ship that he's
originally on the Sprite where there's a
kind of messed up family
situation
and then you know being stuck on the
Corinthian and figuring out what their
you know how he's going to fit in there
Tom has to
deal with that and so there's all sorts
of
not absolute traumas but Damage Done to
the person that they have to figure out
how to progressively take a look at and
heal and start to go beyond and this is
always going to involve in every one of
these cases if not being connected with
the entire ship as a whole although we
can say that in every case the character
you know in the case of sander he's
already connected with the ship as a
whole but he gets connected with
something larger than that ship as well
the patronage of Dublin again being
involved with the uh the alliance Fleet
and things along those lines but with
everybody else they're coming onto a
ship and figuring out how to place
themselves how to build up relationships
through misunderstandings through
missteps through dealing with difficult
situations of conflict
figuring out who they can trust and who
they can't who's rotten who's corrupt
who's just venial who can be relied upon
who has a good heart how far the
relationship can go
and all of this within Frameworks of
rules that are there in part to keep
everybody alive and to allow there to be
a mission a teleology a you know we're
about this sort of thing and that may be
changing you know for example in
Infinity's end we find out that you know
affinity's end has been one of the
alliance Fleet warships and they want to
change back to legitimate trade and this
is going to require
um you know showing their character as a
family as a ship as a whole so each one
of these main characters and many of the
other characters as well that are
connected with them are caught up within
this situation where they always have to
make decisions and they have to decide
what is going to to be valuable and be
prioritized the ethical choice for
themselves and what is going to be
allowed to take second place or even be
ruled out altogether sometimes this is
values sometimes this is Cargo sometimes
this is missions sometimes this is
people and relationships and even their
own conception of themself and so what
we see and interestingly each of these
merchanter novels
is growth taking place on the part of
the main character each of them you
could say is in a certain way even
though in in a few of them we're talking
about you know young adults or even
middle-aged adults
it could be called The Coming of Age
novel if that wasn't such a trivial way
to talk about it instead perhaps we
should think about these as
opposing ethical problems issues
dilemmas that then are resolved through
the narrative and not perfectly and
sometimes leaving things behind so you
know for example by the time we get to
the end of affinity's end we see that
you know finity's end has succeeded in
bringing about this new configuration of
the merchanders in both you know
Alliance and Union territory and
Fletcher now fits into the crew and the
you know that the captain is actually
dying and having to be uh you know
replaced by a new generation a very nice
resolution in TriPoint we have leaving
behind his old ship forging a
relationship with his Wiley half-brother
carrying on a romantic relationship with
one of the crew members and deciding to
take a different direction in life in
Rim Runners it's a little bit less you
know clear about where things are going
but there's a resolution and
interestingly in merchander's luck we
began with a love story and at the very
end of merchanter's luck it's not clear
where Allison and sandor really are with
each other anymore
you know it finishes up uh talking about
what they're going to be doing she went
out with seeing did with empty holes
moving lightly as she could in that
condition comp talked to them commending
them that they'd got it right jump
coming up Sandy find your reference got
it Allison said from number two post
take talking back to Compton to him and
the numbers came up on the screen the
checks came in from the others routine
matters they headed for Pell for station
cargo this time and reckoned Dublin
would pass them on the way there was a
bet on inside the scene about elapsed
time and drinks when they got there he
reckoned to win it knowing a ship but it
was all one account anyway right they
they're all part of a combine now so
this is a really important theme I think
and it takes a while and it takes a
certain attentiveness to see this I will
close by saying that had I read these
when I was much younger I probably would
have paid less a 10 attention to the
ethical dimensions
of the person and the development and
you know relationships in these stories
and I probably would have been you know
born at those points as I often was but
now I see that this is one of the great
strengths of chera's writing in these
merchanter novels that are so rich in so
many different dimensions but the
ethical Dimension absolutely important
so that brings this to a close a little
bit longer than I had expected I hope
that if you haven't read these that
you'll go out and get them and read your
way through them CJ Chara is quite an
amazing author and who knows maybe
someday down the line we might see more
of this material coming out as well but
for the time being that is it for this
session
[Music]
thank you foreign